a court in Egypt this week sentenced
four men up to eight years in prison for
yeah homosexuality prosecutors had
accused the men of holding quote deviant
parties and they're using a law that
bans debauchery - to put these guys in
jail and put them on trial the Middle
East seems to be pretty backwards as
we've talked often about related to
anything with human rights women's
rights gay rights etc etc we've got a
map that it gives you a little more
about gay rights around the globe and
basically red and the darker red you are
the worse it is blue and the darker blue
you are the better it is and and grey
it's pretty it's pretty decent how do we
get the middle east into the 21st
century
I get it we're not perfect here we do
not have full marriage equality here we
got plenty of problems here but how do
we get that section of the world to at
least come a little bit further in this
direction well funny you should say the
word come in that question because if
they look at their own history Egypt
gave you Cleopatra who was one of the
more sexually deviant characters in
history apparently this woman used to
have hundreds of men contribute to her
baths good for her skin or whatever and
I was like and now we have an issue with
one-on-one I was like I don't know I
don't understand the logic what hundreds
of men did what to contribute to her
baths contribute come in a bathtub and
she would bathe in it I've never heard
that are you kidding me it's all over
the Internet
I've never so she was yeah she was bait
wow I did not know that isn't true it's
it's one of she a [ __ ] with sexually
deviant whether or not that's like a
mythological whatever you know what I
mean if you're kind of like and every I
love it all these conservative cultures
even like Asian in me outlets you know
I'll just point her to myself Chinese
history there's some weird-ass [ __ ] that
went down and then they're like oh no
gay people no gay people I'm like really
because y'all did some kinky ass [ __ ]
back in your dynasties yeah yeah do we
have any right to the question
I said get them to look at their own
history and realize the hypocrisy and
you know like where did we come from
where we got win well I guess that in
the case of Egypt so that's a place
where science and liberalism were
rewarded a little more a long time ago
and they've sort of gone backwards do we
have any right in the United States to
tell these people how to live well I
know all the YouTube commenters are
going to say no because every time I
pose that question
everyone yells and says you you know we
need to mind our own business it's a
different culture yeah
what should we care about the their
human rights well I think we should my
my we are human beings and we are tied
by that threat by eighth most viewed
country is Saudi Arabia which is
interesting right on that map in color
red you know in it's amazing I think
what's being done on YouTube not that
we're saving the world or curing cancer
or you know but I think it is a step in
that journey towards getting people to
move a little bit forward with the way
that they view gay rights do you get a
lot of comments from from people from
Saudi Arabia in that part of the world
because we did a video last week about
women driving in Saudi Arabia and I
actually got a lot of men from Saudi
Arabia angry saying that women shouldn't
be allowed to drive and if you let women
drive there's gonna be more car
accidents all that stuff and I kind of
felt bad for them more than anything
else because they're just being
indoctrinated with this stuff so it's
like I can't hate them really because
that's what they're being taught but you
get a lot of comments on your videos I
get a lot of emails from people that are
in countries where it's like not as
accepted but the important thing is like
you're starting a dialogue like you're
starting a conversation that they might
not otherwise have yeah and like is it
going to solve all the problems no but
maybe it's gonna get that ball moving a
little bit yeah is there anything that
the governments should do I mean should
we be Egypt is our ally we give them a
lot of money
should that be contingent on human
rights I think I think we should tread
carefully because I don't understand
what's going on when it comes to
business affairs I don't run this
country I'm not a policymaker because I
know that there's a lot I try and I
thought it said policymaking here isn't
to me Dave Urban make them listen to me
oh but yeah I mean there's a lot that
goes on we don't know kind of wheel
wheel in and eelain goes on between
these world leaders and I think in order
to protect American interests we have to
tread carefully when we stick our nose
in other people's business but with that
being said human to human I think that's
why we do what we do because
I like reaching people on a personal
level I to get a lot of people in these
very conservative countries including
the Middle East as well as parts of Asia
who in their closeted and they're scared
and I do what I can from that level but
I and that's that's the only thing I'm
able to do at this point yeah well I
guess everyone does they're a little
part by the way we should note that gay
cities which is a big gay website they
did their poll of what the best gay city
is in the world and last year it was Tel
Aviv Israel which is smack in the middle
of the Middle East what is with those
crazy Jews that they're down with the
gays while everybody else around them
seems to want to kill them